voici un césar je vais pas en faire une
langue tu pourra en faire un rapport et
voici césar césar baldaccini le
sculpteur de la statue qui récompensent
le cinéma français chaque année
oui j'habite à la banlieue marseillaise
tout près d'ici
il a aussi laissé son nom à la cérémonie
en 1976 ce soir pour la première année
on va remettre les récompenses du cinéma
français
les césar
sa spécialité depuis les années 50 les
compressions à commencer par des épaves
de voitures
j'ai trouvé ça tellement beau tellement
passionnant
que je les ai prises et je vous ai
montré d'une manière très honnête c'est
pas du tout un canular je voulais
montrer que la machine pouvait arriver à
faire une certaine chose est certaine
destruction qui était en même temps
aussi
ah non c ra compresser des bijoux sont
possibles des portes et du carton des
conserves des emballages des chiffons
des motos en 1976 son ami georges
cravenne inventeur de la cérémonie lui
demande de créer une récompense qui
n'était pas la même qu'aujourd'hui je
crois qu'à une partie concrètes dans sa
sculpture qui est ce personnage
enroulait de pellicule de film est
perché sur une roue qui est un peu la
roue de la fortune
mais cas c'est une bobine de film
certaines personnalités auraient était
dubitative face à l'objet alors l'année
suivante c'est à revient à ses
spécialités et compresse des objets
métalliques pour en faire le moule du
césar roux qui pensait enfin avoir une
voiture
je remercie le césar devrait avoir mis
dans cet état là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]